la bandera ucraniana vuelve a ondear
sobre jarque en la segunda ciudad más
grande de ucrania hay señales de que la
vida está volviendo más de un millón de
personas vivían aquí antes de la guerra
actualmente las autoridades estiman que
más del 95% de sus habitantes son
refugiados que han vuelto a casa
la situación en la ciudad es complicada
pero la gente está volviendo todo el
mundo tiene nostalgia también traje a mi
familia de vuelta hace poco porque todos
estamos cansados de vivir en el
extranjero ya es bastante duro ser un
refugiado
después de tres meses de guerra la
ocupación rusa y con combates aún
librándose en las afueras de la ciudad
los daños son numerosos y visibles en
todas partes la población se está
organizando para empezar a limpiar y
reparar
en el séptimo piso se puede ver un
agujero en el balcón cayó un proyectil
pero no explotó no se quemó pero todo
quedó destruido ya no teníamos
apartamento en las tres habitaciones
agarramos lo que pudimos y pusimos todo
en los vehículos
hasta permitirle what motion muchas
personas solo han venido a traer algunas
cosas sus casas son inhabitables este es
el caso de este hombre que todavía tiene
a su familia en el extranjero
esta era una zona prohibida para los
civiles cuando volví esto es una pena
estoy triste porque vivía aquí con mi
mujer y dos chicas
en los últimos días también se ha
reabierto el metro de jarque ya que la
alcaldía quiere facilitar la
recuperación de la economía